- [Voiceover] Lisa, hi sweetheart!
- Hi Mom!
- You look great!
- [Lisa] Thank you.
- Oh you're just so put
together, you look fantastic.
Look at you havin' a good time out in LA.
- Thanks, Mom.
- Miley, you're still
not wearing earrings.
Hey Lisa, can you loan her some earrings?
- Oh yeah, yeah, I brought a few pairs.
- Actually those are my
earrings that she's wearing.
- I thought these were a gift.
- I asked you to return them to me
a long time ago.
Lisa.
Lisa why are you takin'
pictures right now?
- I just want to get the moment.
- Can you not post it?
- Oh no, you're really cute.
- Can you please not post
it, I don't like it, Lisa.
Come on.
- Posted, posted, it's already done.
It's already done.
I can't stop it.
I just have this assumption in my head.
- Yes, caplis are supposed
to be good-lookin'.
- Yeah, that they're--
- Can you stop twirlin' your hair, please?
- What?
- Because.
You know, I look like a trash person,
like I look like a trash can.
- You look--
- Your hair in that picture.
- No, you look good.
- Yes I do.
Please delete it.
- You look great.
- Can you delete it?
I feel like you're just like
makin' me feel some type of way
'cause you know I'm
transitioning right now.
I'm gonna report your page.
Yeah.
You think you're cute.
- It's factual.
- Oh my God.
- I can't help it.
- Ready?
- Yeah, do you mind
if maybe I just tried this on?
Just I've been looking at it.
- Yeah, Lisa, try it on.
You look good in it.
- Really?
- Yeah, you look like a princess.
Lisa just come out this thing.
Just come out.
- [Lisa] Well you know how
I am, I have to be cautious.
- No.
There's nobody on the--
- You never know.
That's how you hit a kid.
(radio changing stations)
Okay, can you just pick something?
- I'm trying to get to something good.
You were dating that boy.
- No.
- Yes you were.
- No, not at all.
You were dating--
- We were close, we were close friends,
I was not dating him.
- I saw you kiss him.
- No.
- Yes I did.
- No, you're making that up.
Nice.
Can you take one of just me?
- My gosh, you're so cliche.
- I'm visiting.
Okay, this is a vacation.
- Fine.
- Bye Mom, thank you.
Okay.
- Bye darlin'.
You can always move back,
move in with your sister,
really nice place.
- No, no.
- No, Mom, no no no.
- Okay, okay, bye, bye.
- Bye.
Wait Lisa, my jacket.
Lisa, give me back my jacket.
Your daughter is about to die,
I'm telling you right now.